alors l'assassinat de Jean-Marie Gibou
ni moins du FLNKS alors c'était l'homme
d'accord de Matignon c'est précisément
ces images que nous allons revoir avec
un commentaire de relancer et après nous
parlerons de Jean-Marie nous fera un
portrait de lui et les commentaires de
Gilles Leclerc mais d'abord les accords
de Matignon c'était il y a quelques
temps
juin 1988 accorde Matignon Jean-Marie
Djibaou et Jacques Lafleur les deux
ennemis réductibles autour d'une table
la Morse d'un processus qui devait
déboucher vers la paix c'était le début
du dialogue
depuis 15 jours au terme de longues
heures de négociation
les délégations de nouvelles Calédonie
conduite par Monsieur Lafleur et chibaou
ont ensemble donner leur accord
à ce que l'État reprennent pour les 12
prochains mois
l'autorité administrative sur le
territoire de manière à garantir
la partialité de l'action publique
la sécurité et la protection de tous
doivent être assurées
des actions de développement économique
et social et de formation
seront mises en oeuvre notamment pour
les régions défavorisées à l'automne je
proposerai monsieur le Président de la
République
qui a suivi avec une extrême attention
l'ensemble de ses conversations
que le peuple français soit consulté par
référendum
sur ces institutions nouvelles
afin qu'il apporte lui il le peuple
français SA garantit la plus haute la
plus fiable la plus durable
dans 10 ans dans 10 ans par un nouveau
scrutin d'autodétermination
c'est à nos compatriotes de nouvelles
Calédonie eux-mêmes
qu'il appartiendra de choisir les voies
et moyens de leur destin et le sentiment
après 15 jours de négociation de travail
que nous avons réussi à comprendre
tout ce temps que nous sommes
que nous devions
savoir donner
savoir pardonner
et c'est ce que nous sommes parvenus à
faire je le crois pour l'avenir choisir
entre pouvoir travailler en sécurité et
s'entretuer je pense que
les délégation était consciente c'était
même émouvant parfois et je pense que
Nathalie même si pour les militants
c'est un peu de
tête dans l'immédiat parce que l'avenir
sera
reconnaître que ces accords ont
constitué par important
des militants qu'il fallait encore
convaincre et qui sont peut-être à
l'origine de l'assassinat de Jean-Marie
Djibaou selon les premières informations
des militants du fulpe l'une des
composantes d'extrême gauche du FLNKS
serait à l'origine de l'attentat
Jean-Marie Djibaou avait 53 ans